goldene kette bestellt habe jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ich hoffe es
funktioniert etwas bedarf und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir haben
jetzt zwei wundervolle sorgten die ich
gerade im ersten part er warte mal so
wir haben dort schon ein video gedreht
dazu und da waren unter anderem diese
socken dabei keine ahnung warum ich das
jetzt erzähle aber falls ihr den partner
nicht gesehen hat mit den ersten zehn
kostenlosen milchprodukten mit bänken
auf jeden fall ab weil jetzt gibt es im
ich habe euch ja gesagt dass ich sehe
mich ziemlich viele bestellt haben und
wir legen jetzt wieder genau zehn sachen
rum
deswegen würde ich sagen wir lange
schlange an die das jetzt zum ersten mal
sehen also ruhig ist eine plattform da
kann man ziemlich viele sachen kaufen
vieles kommt aus china manches kommt aus
amerika vieles sehr günstig und das sind
jetzt halt alles sachen die werden auf
der plattform als gratis angeboten man
muss halt dann meistens nur den versand
bezahlen da immer zwischen 1 bis 3 euro
liegt bei so kleinen produkten wie wenig
ihr halt haben genauso viel dazu ich war
ganz eins nach dem anderen aus
umgeschaut was sich heute davon lohnt
und was überhaupt nicht und was ich euch
vielleicht auch empfehlen kann also
bleibt dran abonniert den kanal
aktiviert die glocke wir starten jetzt
mit dem ausgang ok fangen wir mal mit
dem kleinsten paket an
wir blenden euch auch hier immer das
produkt ein also wie sollte auf der
website so angezeigt wird und dass ihr
kommt ganz klar aus china haben wir
können wir sehen chinesische
schriftzeichen ich habe heute den ich
überhaupt keine ahnung was da drin ist
deswegen haben also was habe ich mir
damals gedacht ich habe wirklich einfach
fast alles bestellt außer so am ende
also alles was kostenlos war aber mir in
den warenkorb und hier haben wir eine
kreditkarten halten
das ist das meine kreditkarte soll ich
da rein tun das ist bestimmt seine
schlüssel plakat oder nicht das ist
wirklich so
warum hat es das james bond ohne spaß da
kann ich mich erst gar nicht daran
erinnern dass ich das bestellt haben
oder ich habe einfach gedacht
kreditkarte die kaufe ich sehr krass ja
das wahrscheinlich halt also to sin
schlüsselloch und dann kannst du das auf
knacken wenn du wenn du das kannst also
ich kann mir wirklich vorstellen dass es
mit solche sachen
wir können ja mal versuchen warte nein
natürlich funktioniert also ich kann mir
wirklich gut vorstellen dass wenn man
sich damit auskennen dass das wirklich
klappen kann deswegen ich studiere dass
man ein bisschen und bewahrt das auf
jeden fall auch kleines gadget kann ich
euch empfehlen wenn ihr auch mal vorab
so gehe ich irgendwie in der bank
einzubrechen
also hier nochmals sowie das aus
produkte mal eins ich feiert also ist
geil
leute wir machen weiter mit produkte mal
zwei kann man hier ist sogar krass wie
steht es wirklich das richtige
traumkleid kunden kümmert 2 ich habe
absolut keinen plan was das hier sein
soll
jetzt weiß es für zahnbürsten gut oder
muss jetzt hier reingehen kann man ganz
einfach ins bad kleben
ich bin so unfähig auf jeden fall kann
man hier seine zahnbürste zahnpasta was
auch immer reinhauen und ich meine wo
christa das sonst gratis her ist
eigentlich schon gut aber das ist das
hier so hoteladresse
ja ich glaube dass das wirklich halt ein
glas oder an marmor oder so kleben weißt
du nicht leben aber hängen sollte bei
10.000 stellen wir demnächst nur eis
taut produkte wirklich okay wir kommen
zu produkten vom heutigen ruhig unboxing
[Applaus]
weißt du was das ist liebling kit das
hier ist ein bleaching gerät also dass
ballert man halt zwischen die zähne und
dann werden die zähne weiß aber ich
glaube da braucht man auch so eine creme
für meister und das leuchtet dann halt
und hier fehlt sogar die batterie das
heißt das ist wirklich nur dieses gerät
ich habe leider jetzt hier keine knopf
worte ich habe leider jetzt hier keine
knopf batterie und wir haben heute
sonntag also der ganzen supermärkte
haben zu aber ich würde das römer
ausprobieren
meinetwegen wenn ihr sagt alex trägst du
das mal schreibt die kommentare bei
steckte zahnunfall und dann werde ich
das mal testen allerdings geht es heute
leider nicht tut mir leid ich habe keine
batterien was wir machen weiter mit
produkte macht ihr der sache goldkette
leute jetzt fast auf jetzt willst lösen
was ist das denn für ne scheiß auf das
amt
ich weiß nämlich dass ich so eine
goldene kette bestellt habe aber wenn
das jetzt hier die kette sein soll sogar
wär's ja ja ich hab so eine kette
bestellen und das hier ist ein armband
oder ich habe mich jetzt vertan also
das ist das armband daneben anscheinend
weil ich dieses falsche bestellt hat und
ja gut dann macht es sogar an dieser
stelle sind also ich hab so was bestellt
ich dachte allerdings da kommen so eine
kette an weil das hier einer das ist ja
so ein schrott so kann sie karneval
benutzen aber das war's auch dann muss
man mich sagen bis auf dieses
zahnputzbecher dingen hatten ja heute
noch nichts dabei also da waren im
ersten hat auf jeden fall besser sache
aber wir haben ja noch ein paar und
deswegen machen wir einfach mal hier mit
weiter oha leute das ist eigentlich eine
mega geil
das ist doch eigentlich eine gute
erfindung also da habe ich gedacht das
nimmst du auf jeden fall mit probierte
aus man kann damit drei handys
gleichzeitig laden also ist ein adapter
usb hub habe ich um
hast du auch so was juli hat anette
weise eine teurere variante was dafür
bezahlt kommt nun zehn oder zwanzig
jahre wollte der ist gut er ist gut und
daher sollen nicht gut sein sorgst du
dann kann man jetzt sogar 4 1 2 3 4 und
du hast auch gerne aber von der
verarbeitung her dass halt usb 3.0 zum
letzten mal dass sie nicht klar das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht die beste technik
sein und da stellt sich auch immer die
frage wie lange dann sowas wirklich hält
aber wir können ja wenigstens mal kurz
ausprobieren ob man damit wirklich ein
handy zum laden kriecht und jetzt muss
ja eigentlich das handy angeben
guck mal funktioniert von daher also
beschwerden kann man sich daher weniger
ins kostenlos ist kann ich euch dieses
produkt auf jeden fall empfehlen also
ist das öffentlichste kostet zwei euro
versagen keine ahnung vom heutigen video
auf jeden fall das beste mit abstand ich
werde auf jeden fall normalerweise eher
weniger berg heimisch denn normalerweise
eher weniger
das fühlt sich so anderer stelle gar
nicht und was habe ich denn hier
bestellt sollte das ist für mich so ich
freue mich eigentlich bei jeder neuen
sache komme ich kann zehn sachen
auspackten und immer ist es so man weiß
halt ich was drin ist also so richtig
geburtstags vielen ich weiß was es ist
und zwar ein laserpointer verkleidet als
kugelschreiber zu
dann darf ich sie ganz herzlich begrüßen
zu ersten stunde des geografie kurses
heute geht es um die wunderschöne stadt
was meinst du das passt das pascha
befindet sich also im vordergrund sehen
wir die wunderschöne kathedrale von köln
welt
weltkulturerbe auch bekannt als der
kölner dom oder auch das kölner archiv
vierte oder chinesischer markt platziert
oder auch chinesisch am startplatz
richtig sehr gut und das pascha sehr
bekannt in köln kann ich euch alle
empfehlen da mal vorbeizuschauen wenn
noch mal auf kleine schritte explosion
gehen da geht man einfach hier vorbei
dann richtung ehrenfeld und hinter ihrem
feld kann man dann ein großes gebäude
sehen blinkt manchmal nachts und da seid
ihr dann richtig der laser freuen davon
so wieder auf jeden fall echt jetzt
alter weiter das gut aus ich weiß nicht
ob das so gut ich hatte noch nie ohne
spaß der komplett gratis und er ist so
stark
ich hatte noch nie so starken
laserpointer dadurch fühle mich jetzt
auf jeden fall in nächster zeit also
auch hier an die leute die gerne mal
flugzeuge blenden kann ich empfehlen
ich habe schon ziemlich viele böse
sachen gesagt in einem video also das
meine ich alles nicht ein paar sachen
haben wir noch ich bin mal gespannt was
hier drin ist
das hat nichts mit dem heutigen video zu
tun ich habe nämlich auch noch ein video
geplant da geht es um küchen mit gadgets
von wish also weil ich ja öfter mal ein
video scorer habe ich gedacht das kann
es eigentlich auch machen das gibt es
auch noch in nächster zeit freut euch
gerne drauf ach genau so wie die meisten
ist das ist das leuchtet das ist ein
iphone ladekabel das leuchten kann geil
so ein ganzes kabel kostenlos weiß
natürlich ist das jetzt nicht im
original von apple
aber wenn man die bei apple kauft was
kosten die 17 euro +2 hier ja genau
denn man gespannt komm lass uns mal
einmal das licht ausmachen obwohl das
uns dass dieses produkt aus platten oder
das test werden als letztes okay noch
knapp die idee lag das an einem neuen
usb habe ja
leute dann kommen jetzt zum letzten
produkt für das heutige video was hier
drin ist weiß ich nicht genau
habe ich jetzt auch schon zum zehnten
mal gesagt dass jedes mal alles drin ist
nichts mit den wald jedes mal also was
hier drin ist weiß ich nicht genau
deswegen finden wir es heraus ich fühle
mich wirklich als hätte ich heute
geburtstag
da habe ich mich so darauf gefreut
das ist ein richtig gutes gadget für die
hybrid weißt du warum das schreibst du
unter den wasserhahn und da kommt
automatisch kühlmittel raus das heißt du
brauchst gar kein spiel mit wem er
immerhin zu geben das kommt automatisch
von mit aus dem wasserhahn
das lässt man geld machen das sind so
kügelchen ob das jetzt gutes spülmittel
ist weil sie nicht kommt der glaube ich
will raus nähe oder nicht so richtig
glauben dass mal kurz im badisch glaubt
da geht was er drauf es ist das packe
ich doch auch keinen bock
also irgendwie funktioniert das jetzt
nicht so ganz
muss man halt sagen oder macht irgendwas
falsch ich glaube tatsächlich ich glaube
nicht es war ein kleiner fehler von mir
und zwar ist das irgendwie falsch im
kopf oder ich hab es falsch gedeutet auf
jeden fall ist es kein will mittel da
drin sondern einen wasserfilter zeigt
gern mal das bild da wir blenden euch
das ein der geht durch verschiedene
zonen durch weste und dann ist das
wasser oder soll das wasser komplett
clean sein ob das jetzt wirklich der
fall ist mit seinen dingen was aus china
kommt mag ich stark zu bezweifeln aber
gut
übrigens ich weiß hier unten steht jetzt
immer ein euro ich habe es allerdings
kostenlos gekauft manchmal variiert das
halt dann kostet das plötzlich doch
wieder in europa ein paar woran es liegt
bevor wir diesen fällen haben jetzt noch
ein geld ist auch dass ich mich
eigentlich am meisten freue und zwar ein
grün leuchtendes led iphone ladekabel
also wir haben es dunkel gemacht und
jetzt ist die aufgabe ich benutze jemand
usb hub steckt das macbook und jetzt
so und jetzt brauchen wir noch dieses
led ladekabel was jetzt in diesem hat
mit rein kommt jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ich hoffe es funktioniert leute
gebt euch das also ich weiss mega das
wichtigste ist aber natürlich dass das
jetzt lädt ab ins iphone und co es lädt
da kann man sich auf jeden fall am
wenigsten beschweren ist meiner meinung
nach mit dem led unternehmen mit diesem
laser pointer und das hatten wir noch
keine ahnung das sind die beiden kurzen
sachen für das heutige video
ich hoffe auch dieser partner durch
gefallen lassen doch nach oben da
schreibt gerne weitere video wünsche in
die kommentare
abonniert den kanal aktiviert die glocke
das was von mir
ich genieße jetzt noch den rest des
tages im grünen und aus rein